Vom, peut-être que nous pouvons un podcast bilingue ou quattrolingue. Ah, quel que c'est... Simefe, prosciutto, margarine, margarine, margaret, simmefe, Madrid, Sevilla, Barcelona, Milan, Roma, Napoli, Palermo, Madrid, Sevilla, Bourbon, Bourdieu, Cortes, Hermoneras, Cortes, cantare, el chocolat, si claro, graffitti, oh que bello, cantare, el chocolat, si claro, graffitti, oh que bello, cantare, el chocolat, si claro, graffitti, oh que bello, cantare, el chocolat, si claro, graffitti, oh que bello, cantare, el chocolat, si claro, graffitti, oh que bello, cantare, el chocolat, si claro, graffitti, oh que bello, cantare, el chocolat, si claro, graffitti, oh que bello, cantare, el chocolat, si claro, graffitti, graffitti, oh que bello, cantare, el chocolat, si claro, graffitti, graffitti, oh que bello, cantare, el chocolat, si claro, graffitti, graffitti, oh que bello, cantare, el chocolat, si claro, graffitti, graffitti, oh que bello, Einen wunderschönen guten Tag, alle ganz willkommen zu dieser neuen Folge. Das finde ich fantastisch. Sehr, sehr schönes Intro. Vielen, vielen Dank an Tim, der noch mal den Globus gedreht hat und es noch mit dem Schnelldurchlauf alle Länder der Welt gezeigt hat. Tim, Schatz, komm jetzt endlich mal, ich habe dich schon seit Wochen nicht mehr gesehen, was machst du denn da an deinem Rechner? Ich muss mir 310 Folgen über den Podcast-Sofa anhören. Wollen wir mir vorstellen, dass Tim erst mal gelacht hat bei dieser Idee, die sich dann hingesetzt hat und es war erst ganz lustig, weil er diese eine Stelle gehört hat, wo wir mal multilingual gesprochen haben. Und dann aber, wie sein Gesicht immer weniger lachen hatte, immer ernster wurde, weil er sich sehr viele Folgen nochmal angucken musste. Und er an dem Projekt auch so lange gearbeitet hat, dass ihm irgendwann der Podcast gar nicht mehr gefallen hat. Irgendwie er hört, privat ist nur noch fest und flauschig, will sich da aber noch durchkämpfen zu Ende. Aber es hat sich gelohnt, sehr, sehr schön, sehr tim und auch ein schöner Song im Hintergrund, sehr begabter Musiker. Ich schaue mir das aber so Zodiac-mäßig vor, dass er irgendwann diese Obsession, das auch zu Ende zu bringen, entwickelt hat und so. Und dann Frau und
Kinder sind ausgezogen und so, irgendwann hängt man noch
an diesem alten 80s-Telefon
hängt dann noch so ein Post-it.
Wir sind zu Margaret gefahren.
Und ja, jetzt ist Tim alleine, aber
dieses Magnum Opus
an den Start gebracht. Fantastisch. Und jetzt Tim hat auf
Senden gedrückt und sitzt alleine nur in Unterhose
in seiner komplett leeren Wohnung, nur noch
diese Umzugskartons mit Akten und Timecodes in allem. Und jetzt sagt er, es ist erledigt, ich bin am Ende. Und in dem Film Noir seines Lebens sagt er, aber zu welchem Preis, ich wusste es nicht. Und dann geht der Abspann los und er läuft durch die Strasse, man sieht ihn in der Ferne immer kleiner werden. Sehr schön. Ja, das ist Stefan Tietze, den ihr hier reden hört. Viele von euch haben ihn sich zurückgewünscht, er war die letzten Folgen nicht dabei. Grosser Aufschrei, viele Leute haben gesagt, wir wollen Stefan zurück, er soll zurück in den Podcast. Heute ist er hier, hallo Stefan, herzlich willkommen zurück. Hallo, Florian ist auch mal wieder dabei. Ja, wir waren in den letzten Folgen ein bisschen andere Besitzungen, haben wir mal ausprobiert, bisschen rumgewürfelt, auch mal, genau, Redakteure, Red Redakteurinnen hinter den Kulissen vor das Mikro gelassen. Ja, wenn ihr das jetzt 2025 oder so hört, werdet ihr die Folgen nicht mehr finden. Die wurden alle gelöscht, weil der Aufstreit so groß war. Jetzt sind wir wieder zu zweit vom Telefon, hätte ich was gesagt, von diesem Dosentelefon, was man Mikrofone nennt. Und der da spricht, ist Florentin Will, das habe ich glaube ich gerade schon gesagt, aber damit ihr euch das auch wirklich merken könnt. Florentin Will. Ja, sehr nett. Ja, wir haben so den klassischen Theater-Derrieren-Trick gemacht, dass wir einmal die Gewerke durchmischen, dass einmal der Lichtmann darf ans Mikrofon, wir machen die Social Media und es war wild, eine wilde Zeit, aber wie erwartet hat es nicht funktioniert. Wollten wir auch mal bei Gute Arbeit Originals machen, hatten wir auch mal die Idee, dass wir mal ein Sketch die Besetzung tauschen, dass wir die Kamera machen und Make-up steht vor der Kamera und so. An Gewerke tauscht. Ich glaube, es gab damals beim Neo Magazin schon die Idee, quasi jetzt alle mal was anderes machen für eine ganze Sendung, aber dann kommt es immer zu dem Moment, wenn es dann konkret durchgespielt wird, dass allen gleichzeitig aufgeht, dass es total unlustig ist in der Praxis und viel lustiger in der Vorstellung. Und dann kam es zu diesem Moment, wo alle gleichzeitig fällt das auf und alle sagen gleichzeitig, ah nee, oder sollten wir das vielleicht doch nicht machen, weil es doch nicht so lustig ist in der Realität. Irgendwann sagen dann die Produzenten im Autorenraum, nee, wir finden das doch nicht so lustig, wir würden es dann doch anders machen. Aber es ist schwierig, weil vor allem, wenn du halt jemanden an der Kamera hast, der die nicht bedienen kann, dann geht die Sendung halt auch einfach nicht los, weil der kriegt die Kamera nicht an, alles unscharf. Aber wir hatten mal einen Sketch bei Guter Arbeit Originals, der so ein bisschen verkorkst war und wir haben uns überlegt, ob wir bei dem einfach behaupten sollen, dass wir diesen Gewerketausch gemacht haben, um zu erklären, warum der nicht so ganz funktioniert. Aber dann haben wir uns auch dagegen entschieden, dass dann für die Zuschauer wenig Mehrwert hat. Ja, und auch was man bei guter Arbeit immer sagen muss, selbst die schlechtesten Sketche sahen fantastisch aus. Das stimmt. Von daher ist es immer so schwierig zu erklären. Also wir können alle, selbst die Leute, die dann die Produzenten, die an die Kamera gesetzt wurden, konnten halt wahnsinnig gut die Kamera bedienen. Oder Kameraarbeit ist auch einfach wahnsinnig leicht. Ich meine, in vielen Kindershows waren Kinder an der Kamera. Da haben die einfach kinderarbeitmäßig gesagt, jetzt macht ihr das, haben die da festgefesselt, die mussten stundenlang Kameramann sein. Genau, Sonne lacht, Blende acht und so. Und es ist, glaube ich, sehr einfach. Es gibt sehr viele einfache, gut funktionierende Sprichwörter, um sich da zu merken. Das ist übrigens ein gutes Beispiel für ein gutes Sprichwort, also gute Edelsbrücke. Genau. Sonne lacht, Blende acht. Wunderbar. Wahrscheinlich ist es eine hohe Blende und die muss hochgeballert werden, wenn die Sonne ins Objektiv ballert. Und das ist doch super, weil Regen lacht nicht, Sonne lacht. Es ist immer klar, hell, Bände acht. Genau. Super. Es ist super. Andere Sprichwörter, wo sich genau der Teil nicht reimt, der wichtig ist. Genau. So dieses klassische, willst du dich billig besaufen, musst du Oettinger kaufen. Sagst du, das geht nicht, weil nichts heilt sich auf den Kern. Alle anderen, die im Magen ... Kannst alles andere einsetzen. Es funktioniert nicht als Sprichwort. Aber hat da damals eigentlich der Jugendschutz mal drauf geschaut auf ein, zwei oder drei mit den Kinder, mit den Kinderkamera-Kindern? Ich glaube ja. Da kam dann das Jugendamt irgendwann vorbei. Was machen sie hier? Es sind nur ganz kleine Dötzchen hinter der Kamera. Und was ist denn mit den Catering-Kindern eigentlich? Auch ganz kleine Dötzchen. Das gesamte Publikum
wurde einfach direkt versklavt.
Ja, und dann kam so ein kleiner, sechsjähriger
Produzent und hat gesagt, ja, das ist
der Kinderkanal, was haben Sie denn erwartet?
Sir, Sir,
Sir, was haben Sie denn erwartet?
Alle einfach die Kinder machen,
finde ich aber auch eine gute Sinne.
Da kommt so ein ganz kleines Mädchen mit so einem Headset an und sagt,
sorry, gibt es hier ein Problem, Dennis?
Psst, können wir bitte hier weitermachen, wir würden gerne die Aufzeichnung zu Ende bringen. Die Aufnahmeleiterin. Aufnahmeleiterin Kind, einfach alle mit Kindern besetzt. Ja, aber war eine schöne Zeit. Ich schaue gerade wieder Schach und beim neuen Turnier, was ich schaue, gibt es einen 13-Jährigen, der mit den ganz Grossen spielt und unfassbar gut ist.
Aber das Einzige, was ihn unterscheidet, ist, das ist ein Online-Turnier, alle sitzen zu Hause, ist, dass er einfach in einem Kinderzimmer sitzt, wo hinten, was aber auch nicht, ist sehr clean für ein Kinderzimmer, also hinten stehen lächerlich viele Pokale, weil er die ja im Schach gewonnen hat, und aber dann auch so ein großes Angry Birds kuscheltier. Sehr süss und er sitzt da und das einzige, was ihn so wirklich unterscheidet von den anderen, ist, dass er wahnsinnig hibbelig ist. Also, dass man merkt, es ist alles ein bisschen langweilig, so lange am Rechner zu sitzen und dann da auf Knöpfe zu drücken. Der wird einfach so ein bisschen, ja, quengelig, also der dann so, man merkt dann, irgendwann fängt da alles an zu wackeln und so und man möchte ihm irgendwie so einen Fidget Cube oder Fidget Spinner geben oder sowas, aber das ist das einzige, was ihn unterscheidet von den anderen, also das Spiel auf dem gleichen Level, das ist ganz schön beeindruckend. Und ist das deine einzige Schwäche, dass er immer das Spiel verliert, weil er auch dann irgendwie hibbelig dann den König nimmt und dann so hin und her und dann so ja, berührt, geführt, das sind die USCE-Regeln, ah gut, und dann Schachmatt einfach. Das sind wirklich die USCE-Regeln. Das war damals, ich war ja auch, glaube ich, eine Woche lang im Schachclub und da wurde dann immer die Geschichte erzählt von diesem berühmten Schachmatt, wurde dann auch auf der Tafel dargestellt und so, wo jemand, wo die in so einer Kneipe Schach spielen und dann der eine noch ein Getränk bestellen will und mit dem König so auf den Tisch haut, so hier noch eine Runde und dann heißt es berührt geführt und dann musste er den König ziehen und dann hat er verloren. Dann bin ich gegangen. Du hast gesagt, jetzt habe ich alles, bis Lachen hast du die Tasche gepackt. Besser wird es nicht, jetzt bin ich raus, jetzt gehe ich nach Hause. Und was da nach für Geschichten, dann bist du rausgegangen und hast noch einen größeren Lacher gehört, in der Klasse Bist rausgegangen und innen drin in der Klasse. Und du hast gesagt. Und ich habe mich mein Leben gefragt, was war dieser zweite Gag? Was ist die noch lustigere Schachgeschichte? Ich dachte, lustiger geht es nicht. Doch Schach ist voller Spaß und Fun. Diese beiden Dinge. Schach plus Fun ist, äh, Spaß plus Fun ist gleich Schach. Ist gleich Schach, ja. Kann man auch herleiten. Nee, und das fand ich sehr lustig. Der wackelt sehr viel und, ähm, ja, wahrscheinlich zieht er irgendwann mal einen Stecker raus oder so. Ach, das ist sehr so. Und kommt dann irgendwann die Mutter rein mit so einem Teller mit so geschnittenen Äpfeln und so hier. Nee, Mama. Mama, ich mach grad Schach. Ja, die Mutter so, wie wär's denn mit dem Läufer hier vielleicht? Mama. Mama, der ist am Rand. Genau, deswegen kam ich auch drauf. Springer am Rand bringt Kummer und Schand. König am Rand, kannst du auch sagen. König am Rand bringt Kummer und Schrand. Ja, also du müsstest sagen, am Rand steht ein Pferd, das ist es mir nicht wert. Genau, ja, zum Beispiel, ja. Genau, ein Pferd, genau, am Rande ein Pferd, das ist gar nichts wert, oder sowas. Können wir das jetzt eigenhändig ändern? Ich meine, die Dirnis haben wir Abbeiss, muss auch Kauen etablieren, können wir vielleicht ein bisschen nischiger die neue Schachregel etablieren? Pferd am Rand bringt Kummer und Schand.
Nee.
Das wäre einfach das Pferd am Rand.
Am Rand steht ein, am Rande ein Pferde.
Am Rand steht ein Springer, das wünscht man sich nimmer.
Ich liebe diese falschen Reime.
Genau, nimmer.
Aber dann denkt man alle, dass jemand im 18. Jahrhundert entstanden ist in Klammern 2022. Am Rand steht ein Springer, damit holt... Damit wirst du kein Gewinner. Ja, oh, Rand steht am Springer, damit wirst du kein Gewinner. Ja, sowas. Finde ich gut. Jan Gustafsson, falls du zuhörst, etablier das mal, halt mal das Poster hoch im nächsten Turnier. Also ich kämpfe generell, und da werde ich noch lange für kämpfen, für Sprichwörter, die Sinn machen, in der Hinsicht, dass sie gar keine Fragen offen lassen. Weil ich denke jedes Mal, Bier auf Wein, das lasse sein, Wein auf Bier, das rate ich dir. Super. Nee, ist nicht super. Aber warum, das reimt sich doch auf das, was relevant ist.
Nee, aber du kannst es anders
sagen, Wein nach Bier.
Ach so, auf.
Das ist auch richtig. Wein vor Bier, das rate ich dir.
Wein vor Bier, das rate ich dir.
Bier vor Wein, das lasse sein.
Also auch das lässt gewisse,
aber ich gebe dir auch schon ein bisschen besser,
weil jetzt irgendwann ist es ja auch drin, aber es muss sich auch das Wichtige reimen, das ist wichtig. Also wir müssen alle Sprichwörter umdenken. Okay, gut, das neue Millennium-Projekt von Stefan Tietze, seine neue Phase ist das Neuschreiben von sämtlichen Sprichwörtern, kannst dann auch so ein kleines Booklet rausbringen, einfach die neue Sprichwortrechtschreibung. Was ist das dünnste, das habe ich mich gefragt, das dünnste Buch, was ich schreiben muss, damit ich einfach ein Buch mal geschrieben habe? Gute Frage, ja. Wie, was ist das, wie dick muss es dann doch sein, mindestens? Weil wir sind beide faul, wir haben beide Bock, aber das bei Wikipedia steht, die haben schon mal ein Buch rausgebracht, so ist die Frage, also wie Was ist das dünnste Buch der Welt? Aber ich will auch nicht Ja, kannst du jetzt lustig, Gags machen, irgendwie gute Rezepte mit Frühlingszwiebeln oder so. Das ist dünn, sowas, halt ein Gag halt, irgendwas, so. Florantins gesammelte Witze. Ja, die grössten Erfolge von so und so. Aber ansonsten das dünnste Buch, ich glaube, es sind Sachen zum Ausschneiden oder Ausknicken oder Ausdrücken oder sowas dann immer sehr, sehr klein. Aber ich will ja nicht in solche Buchclubs oder Lesungen eingeladen werden, wo man dann sagt, oh, Stefan hat ein Heft rausgebracht, Stefan hat eine Broschüre rausgebracht, sondern es soll schon noch als Buch bezeichnet werden. Und dann ist glaube ich wirklich so mindestens 90 Seiten wahrscheinlich, oder? Kann schon sein, ja. Aber ich meine, du kannst ja auch viele Widmungen machen, einfach ganz, ganz viele Widmungenregister, nochmal ganz lang, Gutscheine und so. Also da gibt es ja in der jahrhundertelangen Striftstellerkultur Tricks, wie man sowas strecken kann. Ja, diese Gutscheinkultur. Diese Gutscheinkultur, einfach bei der ersten Bibel gab es auch Gutscheine für einen Schluck Wein, eine Oblate und so war hinten alles drin. Vielleicht sogar die Oblaten selber auch noch hinten in der Bibel drin gewesen. Gibt's das? Zum Ausstanzen. Die Bibel mit Oblaten zum Ausstanzen hinten drin, einfach alles da, alles parat. Die ganze Bibel auf Esspapier geschrieben. Oh ja. Das wäre geil. Das ist eigentlich eine gute Idee. Obladen sind auch Esspapier, machen wir uns doch nichts vor. Ja, langweiliges Esspapier. Langweiliges Boring-Ass. Wer dachte, es geht noch langweiliger? Aber jeden Sonntag finden überall Gottesdienste statt, mit Obladen. Hat mal irgendwer damit was gemacht? Beispiel, Lebensmittelfarbe, Beispiel, mal in so Erdbeersirup getaucht oder sowas. Oder mal so einfach zwei davon und da zwischen Nutella oder so. Genug Nutella. Also es steht ja, es wird ja nie erwähnt, dass da nicht noch was oben drauf sein kann. Alle stellen sich hinten wieder an. So geil. Das sind alle. So ein Schnurrbart, ja. Aber ich meine, das ist das Erste, was Rieses sagen würde, wenn wir da zurückkommen, dass er sagt, ihr esst die pur? Leute, ich habe gesagt, obladen, aber ich dachte, ihr legt da geilen Shrimp oder irgendwie was cooles drauf. Leib Christi mit Nutella. Leib Christi mit Nutella. Ja. Der Leib Christi mit Erdbeere. Man muss dann immer sagen, was man haben will. Ich war mal Messdiener. Warst du auch mal Messdiener? Nein, nein, nein. Schreckliche Zeit. Ich war so nervös immer vor den Gigs, weil dann wurde man für ein Gig gebucht. Und die V-Band war immer cool. V-Band war immer mega cool, Orgel für die Orgel. Und ich hatte immer wahnsinnig Angst, dass ich mir die Choreo merken kann. Weil es steht und fällt ja alles mit dir. Und es gibt ja nichts Humor befreiteres als katholische Gottesdienste. Weil es ist alles durchgetaktet, niemand lacht, es ist keine Margin for Errors. Du musst einfach abliefern, wie ein Roboter als Messdiener. Aber was man halt nicht weiß, es ist so, man sieht auch Leute selten, die anfangen zu joggen. Man sieht selten Messdiener, die anfangen Messdiener zu werden. Die können das immer schon, wenn man in den Gottesdiensten sass. Und ich hatte halt keine Ahnung, was ich da mache. Das ist so immer noch ein Albtraum von mir, wo ich manchmal schweizt, wo ich aufwache, wie ich dann da diesen Gig schmeißen muss, aber habe keine Ahnung, wo ich hinlaufen muss und so. Ja stimmt, es gibt nicht diesen Fahrschulen-Hut, wo man sieht, ah, der hat heute so den ersten Tag, der ist heute einfach, man weiß, okay, ich brems mal ab, nicht zu nah auffahren, so alles in Ordnung. Man riecht also ein Messingergewand, aber auch dann so eine Warnweste noch übergeworfen. Und Schwimmflügel ist einfach zur Sicherheit. Da wundert sich niemand, warum ich mit der Kerze ins Publikum laufe. Schwimmflügeln. Allen ist klar, der ist neu. Und dann laufe ich, glaube ich, währenddessen gegen so eine Säule dreimal.
Ja, und dann hört man auch so Horrorgeschichten, dann die coolen Messdiener, es gibt aber die, zu denen man auch hochgeblickt hat, weil die noch größer waren als man selbst, haben dann so gesagt, ja und wenn du die Kerze hältst und neben dem Evangelium stehst, dann nicht quasi den Kerzenduft die ganze Zeit einatmen. Neulich ist Joe umgekippt. Und dann gibt es einfach Geschichten von so Leuten, die umkippen, weil die die Kerze immer zu sehr unter ihre Nase gehalten haben. Wow. Oben kommt die ganze Zeit CO2 raus und irgendwann pff, kippst du um. Also, horrormässig. Und dann habe ich das auch sein gelassen. Das war ja schrecklich. Gott sei Dank. Ach ja, das war eine schöne Zeit. Messdiener, Messdienerzeit. Währenddessen habe ich gar nichts gemacht. Wenn du das gemacht hast, lag ich im Bett und habe geschlafen. Dafür bist du jetzt ausgeschlafen. Ja, ich bin richtig ausgeschlafen, ja. Ich brauche viel zu viel Schlaf, glaube ich. Ich glaube, das ist nicht gut. Warum? Ich glaube, zu viel Schlaf ist nicht gut. Du schläfst dann immer aus, oder wem? Ja, kannst dann schön lange schlafen. Und das Ding ist, ich habe keinen, ich habe das nicht, diesen Drang, dann aufzustehen manchmal und kann dann einfach weiter schlafen. Also ich kann durchaus quasi, wenn ich keinen Termin habe an einem Tag, kann ich und ich wache so um neun Uhr auf, kann ich mich wieder hinlegen und dann wache ich halt so jede Stunde auf, aber ich kann schon fast, ich kann quasi die ganze Zeit schlafen. Nee, das kann ich überhaupt nicht. Wenn ich einmal aufgewacht bin, ist es vorbei und deswegen gehe ich dann auch sehr hart mit mir ins Gericht, warum ich jetzt um drei Uhr nachts aufgewacht bin. Was ich hätte anders machen können, ob mich jemand geweckt hat, was passiert ist. Das hätte ich wahrscheinlich wach. Ja genau, einfach weil ich hart mit mir ins Gericht gehe, weil ich mir immer denke, der Körper, du willst doch schlafen, du bestrafst mich jetzt den Rest des Tages dafür, dass ich nicht geschlafen habe, aber du hast mich auch aufgeweckt. Also was soll das? Auf welcher Seite bist du hier? In welchem Team bist du gerade?
Und ich habe mich letztens ein bisschen über Schlaf informiert und da hieß es,
je nach Alter wacht jeder Mensch zehn bis fünfundzwanzig Mal in der Nacht auf,
aber man muss ungefähr eine Minute wach sein, damit es ins Langzeitgedächtnis übergeht,
damit man sich danach erinnern kann, dass man wach war. Das heißt, man ist nur so kurz wach, dass man sich am Morgen nicht daran erinnern kann. Aber eigentlich war man die ganze Zeit auch wach. Genau. Das heißt, ich frage mich, sind diese Momente, wo ich dann in der Nacht aufwache, einfach die, wo in diesem Zeitraum irgendwas passiert, dass man sozusagen dann den Absprung nicht kriegt und wieder einschläft, sondern wach bleibt, weil du bist ja
ständig wach, wahrscheinlich immer wenn so ein
Phasenwechsel ist, du hast ja immer so diese Tiefschlag-
Rem-Phasen-Dinger und dann
wenn du ganz oben bist, nach Rem, bist du wahrscheinlich dann wach
und dann hast du die Möglichkeit
dann nochmal einzusteigen oder auszusteigen.
Dein Bewusstsein ist zu schnell, dein Bewusstsein ist zu schnell so, hei, hei,
da bin ich, ach so, ja, ich hab's geschrieben,
direkt aufgeschrieben, ja genau,
hab's geschrieben, ich hab notiert und dann dein Bewusstsein so, nee, komm, strech es durch. Du musst ja nicht immer alles notieren. Ja, aber es ist verrückt, da habe ich einiges gelernt zum Thema Schlaf, weil das Abgefahrenste fand ich, dass wenn du träumst, gibt dein Gehirn die Befehle von den Dingen, die du im Traum machst, auch an die Muskeln weiter. Also wenn du im Traum läufst, gib dein Gehirn Signale, als würdest du jetzt laufen, aber an einem weiteren Punkt, irgendwie im Rückenmark oder so, gibt es dann einen Punkt, wo ein gewisser Stoff ausgeschüttet wird, der diese Signale blockiert. Also der Traumknopf. Genau, der Traumkopf, der sagt, nee, passt schon, der ist betrunken, der ist, nehmt den mal nicht ernst. Den brauche ich immer. Ja, der hat jetzt gerade mal einen schlechten Tag, ignoriert mal, was der sagt gerade. Aber für das Gehirn, das weiss ja nicht, dass die Befehle nicht ankommen, für das Gehirn ist es, glaube ich, wirklich so, als würde man ganz normal schwimmen und laufen und fliegen und was auch immer. Und dann ist nämlich der Punkt, wenn du Schlaf wandelst, dann ist dieses System nicht in Kraft und dann kommen manche Signale durchaus an.
Wackelkontakt.
Das heißt, wenn du dann Christina durch das Internat fliegen siehst, dann träumt sie gerade, dass sie fliegt, aber das Rückenmark hat sich geschafft, das zu verhindern. Wenn sie mit Mahatma Gandhi gerade spricht. Hahaha, na, weißt du das auch?
Wenn sie wunderschön Somebody That I Used To Know singt, während sie irgendwie durchs Gebäude fliegt und mit Kevin rummacht, dann ist das, dann hat sie das Rückenmark nicht gecheckt, dass es gerade eine Traumwelt ist. Genau, wenn du Sabine siehst, die keinen Mund hat und panisch im Mund rumfasst, weil sie keinen Mund mehr hat, dann weißt du, oh, oh, oh, da läuft was falsch. Aber so ist es. Und dann die umgekehrte Version ist dann Schlafparalyse, dass du aufwachst, diese Blockade aber trotzdem noch im Gang ist und du dich nicht bewegen kannst. Das hat man immer nach, wenn man zu schnell aufwacht durch einen Adrenalinrush beim Albtraum oder so, das kenne ich auch. Das ist ja auch krass, dass du wach bist und dein Gehirn gibt Befehle, aber die kommen nicht an und du kannst nichts machen und checkst auch nicht,. Also das sind dann so die beiden Möglichkeiten, dass dieses System falsch läuft. Ich habe auch einen Schlaffunktion, und zwar habe ich gelernt, dass man, wenn man nachts aufbacht, ist man immer schlecht gelaunt. Weil im Schlaf macht ja Sinn, dass der Kopf kein Dopamin und keine Serotonin, also keine Glückshormone ausschüttet, man braucht es ja auch tagsüber nicht. Du füllst einfach deine Akkus auf und am nächsten Tag werden dann wieder bei Dingen, bei Sonne oder was auch immer, guter Musik, können dann wieder Glückshormone ausgeschüttet werden. Aber nachts wird die Produktion komplett runtergefahren und deswegen bist du sehr, sehr schlecht drauf, wenn du nachts aufwachst. Das kennt man ja, wenn man nachts aufwacht, ist man immer ein bisschen mürrisch. Aber seitdem ich diesen Funfact weiss, muss ich darüber immer lachen.
Wenn ich nachts aufwache, denke ich mir immer, ja, bist du schlecht drauf, ne?
Ja, hast du ganz schlechte Laune.
Boah, jetzt wachst du auch noch nachts auf, ne?
Was macht man, der muss ja aufs Klo, oh nein, das ist doch... Ich finde das so doof, weil ich finde das einfach sehr lustig,
dass man so doof chemisch dann jetzt schlecht drauf ist.
Ja, genau. Da hat jemand kein Dopamin dran.
Da bin ich jetzt richtig mürrisch.
Die Hirnchemie ist grad schlecht drauf. Ja, und dann dachte ich mir, aber das muss ja, weil da lache ich dann ernsthaften Nacht ziemlich kaputt drüber, aber das findet ja auch Dopamin aus. Und dann kannst du nicht mehr einschlafen. Dann kann ich ja nicht mehr einschlafen, da bin ich am nächsten Tag schlecht drauf und so. Aber ich finde es sehr gut, sich so zu überlisten, weil wenn man schlecht drauf ist, ist es oft einfach nur jetzt bei gesunden Menschen, dass man halt einfach irgendwie, keine Ahnung, Dopamin gerade nicht produziert, weil man nachts aufgewacht ist. Und dann finde ich es lustig, sich hier drüber zu stellen. Und es hat geholfen eigentlich, dann war ich eigentlich ganz glücklich. Du bist jetzt immer schlecht drauf, aber lachst drüber. Das ist eigentlich eh die Haltung. Da Schluss. Lache nicht kaputt. Ja, das ist schön. Hast du mehr Schlaf-Fun-Facts? Ich finde das toll. Ich finde das Thema Schlaf fantastisch. Diese Rem-Phase ist natürlich sehr, sehr spannend. Dieses Rapid Eye Movement, der wird auch der Paradoxischlaf genannt. Weil obwohl du schläfst, sehr viele Körpersignale sind so, als wärst du wach. Also du hast höheren Blutdruck, hast schnelleren Herzschlag, höherer Puls und all das. Da kommt dann auch die Morgenerektion her, weil du hohen Blutdruck hast. Weil gegen Ende der Nacht werden die REM-Phasen häufiger als die Tiefschlafphasen. Und dann haben die so ein Experiment gemacht. Blutdruck, ich finde das wie wegen der Blase. Wie bitte? Ich dachte das wegen der Blase. Es gibt verschiedene Theorien dazu, ist vielleicht nicht das beliebteste Forschungsthema. Und dann haben die... Ich glaube doch, ehrlich gesagt, das allerbeliebteste Forschungsthema. Was ist da los? Und dann bewegen sich die Augen ja so schnell unter den Liedern, also die Lieder sind zu und die Augen bewegen sich. Und die Forscher haben sich gefragt, warum bewegen die sich, was ist das für eine Bewegung, was soll das? Und dann haben die überlegt, okay, vielleicht hat das was mit Traum zu tun. Und dann haben die Leuten, die luzid träumen können, also die ihren Traum steuern können, denen haben die eine gewisse Abfolge von Augenbewegungen beigebracht. Also dreimal links, viermal rechts, oben unten, links, rechts. Und haben gesagt, wenn ihr luzid träumt, macht das. Und dann haben die sich angeguckt, was die tatsächlich im Schlaf für Augenbewegungen haben. Und die hatten exakt diese Abfolge an Augenbewegungen auch tatsächlich, als die Forscher sie beobachtet haben. Das heißt, du kannst im Schlaf wirklich deine Augen bewegen. Also haben sie damit bewiesen, dass das irgendwas mit dem Traumgeschehen zu tun hat, wie man seine Augen bewegt in dieser Phase. Aber das finde ich jetzt total doof, weil ich dachte immer, luzid Träumende haben Lügen mich an.
Aber jetzt haben die ja dann recht.
Jetzt kriegen die ja dann recht.
Zu einem gewissen Grad haben die Recht, ja. Aber das, dann kannst du ja im Traum nichts verarbeiten. Das heißt, diese Menschen sind auf sich ganz allein gestellt. Ja, das habe ich auch schon mal gehört, dass das ganz cool ist, Lucid zu träumen, aber man ist dann irgendwie, fehlt einem irgendwas. Ja, genau, weil der Traum, sicherlich macht er ja was. Ja, das ist schwer, in Worte zu fassen, aber ich habe mit so einem gesprochen, er meinte ja irgendwie geht es dir danach auch nicht so gut, weil das ist ja wichtig für das emotionale Verarbeiten von Ereignissen, bla bla, aber du fliegst ja immer durch die Stadt. Weil er meinte dann auch so, du kannst im Traum halt auch beliebige Leute beschwören, du kannst ja dann wirklich halt mit Gandhi sprechen, aber er denkt so, ja aber du sprichst ja mit dir selber, aber warum ist Gandhi so schlau, warum ist Gandhi schlauer als du, das bist ja auch du. Das ist wie Aaron Sorkin, der immer gefragt wurde, warum seine ganzen Charaktere so clever sind, ist er auch so clever und er hat gesagt, ja, eigentlich weird, weil er will sich nicht, aber die sind alle viel cleverer als er, aber sie schreiben die ja. Ja, die klingen vielleicht nur clever, aber ich kann gut die clever klingen lassen. Und dann gab es auch so einen Typ von so einem Skateboarder, der war einer der ehrgeizigsten Skateboarder aller Zeiten und hat sich dann verletzt und hat dann aber versucht, weil er nicht tatsächlich skateboarden konnte, im Traum seinen Skateboarden zu üben. Und anscheinend hat das auch geholfen, hat er behauptet. Danach ist er durch die Halfpipe geflogen. Mit Mahatma Gandhi hinten drauf. Es ist verrückt, aber es ist ein Thema, wo vieles auch noch völlig unbekannt ist. Also bei vielen so Schlafsachen liest man dann auch so, ja, keine Ahnung warum. Also es gab im Kindergarten eine Schlafecke, also es war eigentlich so eine, die hieß die Kuschelecke, da hat man sich auf die Couch gelegt und zusammen gelesen und so. Also die Kindergärtnerin hat das dann vorgelesen. Ebenfalls war die immer gesperrt, weil ich darin gepennt habe. Bei uns in der Gruppe. Und dann irgendwann wurde meine Mutter und mein Vater dann angerufen oder so was oder beim Abholen angesprochen, was da mit mir los sei, dass ich sehr viel schlafen würde. Das geht nicht mehr. Also nicht nur ist der Raum die ganze Zeit belegt. Der für acht Kinder ausgelegt ist. Ich habe auch nicht verstanden, warum die mich dann haben schlafen lassen. Das ist das Problem. Die machen nicht wachrütteln die ganze Zeit? Ja, mich wachrütteln. Ich werde ja schon klarkommen, also vielleicht mich ein bisschen groggy und schlecht gelaunt. Aber die haben mich schlafen lassen und dann war es ein Problem. Das würde ich gerne mal wissen, was da genau das Problem war. Weil es ist ja deren Schuld, wenn die mich dann schlafen lassen da. Naja, gut. Oder meine Mutter auch schon, dass sie mich immer haben schlafen lassen. Und dann denke ich mir, wenn ihr mich alle die ganze Zeit schlafen lasst, dann wundert euch ja nicht, warum ich die ganze Zeit schlafe. Ihr habt auch ein bisschen die Aufgabe, dass ich nicht meine Jugend, meine Kinder komplett verschlafe. Ja, ihr habt eine ganze Kindheit. Ja, ihr habt eine ganze Kindheit. Ja, wie so eine Katze einfach, die einfach 23 Stunden am Tag schläft, die irgendwann auch am Lebensende sagt, ja warum weckt ihr mich denn nicht auf, wenn was passiert? Also ich meine, ich kann ja nicht mein ganzes Leben verschlafen. Schon wieder Silvester verschlafen. Ich dachte, ihr weckt mich auf, wenn irgendwas cooles ist. Ihr lasst mich die ganze Zeit schlafen. Aber bei manchen Tieren denke ich das, da habe ich dann immer so eine Doku gesehen, die schlafen 22 Stunden am Tag. So ein Puma oder so. Aber man hat ja so ein schönes Fell und die Natur hat so viel Arbeit da reingestellt. Die Rechnung geht nicht auf. Diese Investition kann sich doch nicht lohnen für Mutter Natur.
Guck mal, dieser Gepard oder dieser Leopard, so schönes Fell und so speziell und hat einen Namen bekommen von uns. Leute, lassen Sie uns doch einmal einen Schritt zurückgehen und überlegen, ob wir da so viel Namen Etymologie reinstecken sollen, ob die Natur da so viel Arbeit hat reinstecken sollen. Wer da die ganze Zeit schläft, macht das keinen Sinn. Es ist wie so ein, keine Ahnung, so ein Tamagotchi, was man weggelegt hat und dann ist es so, es ist so produziert worden, aber dann wofür? Es liegt einfach nur rum. Ja, lass uns mal so eine biologische Schlaf-Kuschelecke machen, wo alle Tiere, die kriegen nur noch Zahlen, die kriegen nur noch Zahlen, die sind in der Ecke und dann kriegt ihr einen coolen Namen zurück. Jetzt heißt es irgendwie Nasenbär, der eh schon namenstechnisch einfach nicht die beste Zeit hatte. Der heißt jetzt Jaguar. Und bis du dich irgendwie mal wieder aufrappelst und mal was machst, kriegt der deinen Namen. Ja. Aber ich call es jetzt, ich call es jetzt schon. Menschen müssen irgendwann nicht mehr schlafen. Wir kriegen irgendwann hier die News reingeflattert in fucking Dino News. Stellt raus, Tyrannosaurus Rex schlief 23 Stunden am Tag. Müde, müde, müde. Und dann rieb er sich die Augen, streckt sich erstmal ein bisschen und dann nochmal umgedreht. Und dann nochmal um und dann einfach eine Stunde husten und dann legt es sich da wieder hin.
Einmal niesen, die 26 Liter müssen dann immer raus und dann einfach eine Stunde husten und dann legt es sich da wieder hin.
Einmal niesen, die 26 Liter müssen dann immer raus und dann wieder auch hingehen.
Hörbe!
Oh Gott, ey, ja.
Hundertprozentig.
Ich verstehe es nicht, ich verstehe Schlaf auch nicht, ich verstehe es wirklich, es macht gar keinen Sinn und ich glaube auch nicht, dass das irgendwie überall der Fall ist.
Vor allem, ich stelle mir vor, warum ist es nicht viel besser, wenn du nachts einfach alle schlafenden Tiere auffrisst? Also warum ist der Löwe nicht einfach nachtaktiv und frisst die schlafenden Gazellen einfach auf? Warum ist das nicht eine viel bessere Strategie? Weil dann würde sich über Jahrzehnte, würde die sich auch der Nachtaktivität aneignen natürlich, weil die Tiere am ehesten überleben, die nachts wach sind. Das heißt, du ... Ja, aber dann schlafen die tagsüber und werden vom anderen Tier gefressen. Dann ist es ja so eine offensichtliche Schwäche. Dann züchtest du eine Spezies, die nur noch wach ist. Und das ist spannend, weil das sind die Gewinnertiere dann. Also du meinst, es ist so ein evolutionäres Pingpong, dass die Löwen irgendwann sagen, okay, die sind jetzt nur noch nachts wach, lass uns auch nachts wieder schlafen und tags wach sein. Und dadurch pendelt sich das irgendwann so ein. Ja, ich glaube auch nicht, dass alle nachtaktiven Tiere immer schon nachtaktiv waren. Ich glaube, das hat sich einfach so eingependelt. Die konnten einfach nicht schlafen. Die konnten einfach nicht schlafen. Die konnten einfach nicht schlafen. Die konnten einfach nicht schlafen. Die konnten einfach nicht schlafen. Die konnten einfach nicht schlafen. Die konnten einfach nicht schlafen. Die konnten einfach nicht schlafen. Genau. Die konnten einfach nicht schlafen. Die konnten einfach nicht schlafen. Die konnten einfach nicht schlafen.
Die konnten einfach nicht schlafen.
Genau.
Die haben die ganze Zeit.
Die haben die ganze Zeit. Vielen Dank. Du musst ja den Ohrwurm noch mal ganz hören, damit der rausgeht, und dann wecken die den so, kannst du das noch mal singen gerade? Okay. Aber gibt's da was? Die Nachtigall ist toll. Die habe ich jetzt in Berlin gehört, wo ich gar nicht wusste, dass da so viele... Das Tier? Ja, achso. Ja, als wir in Berlin waren, hatten wir so ein Hotel, das war eigentlich ganz cool gelegen, in der Nähe vom Tiergarten. Und da sind die wohl ganz viele Nachtigallen. Das war richtig schön. Wie klingen so, wie du gerade gemacht hast? Nee, nee, das war mein Versuch einer Taube. Nachtigallen sind schwer nachzumachen. Die sind auch sehr, und da wollte ich gucken, weil ich wollte hören, sind das die Nachtigallen, die ich gerade höre, weil auch so ein langer ZeitMagazin-Artikel über Nachtigallen, weil sehr viele Leute plötzlich nach Berlin kommen und sich an, keine Ahnung, zu Hause erinnern, wo sie herkommen aus verschiedenen Ländern, weil die die Nachtigall jetzt hier hören, weil es sie plötzlich auch in Berlin gibt. Und wollte ich mir hören, wie das klingt. Und die haben sehr viel, es ist eher so ein Torre, was die verbindet, weil die haben sehr viele verschiedene Melodien, die die singen. Nicht wie lame-ass Tauben, die einen Song haben, einen Banger, muss man sagen, ein richtiger Banger, aber es ist ein One-It-Wonder. Tauben sind fucking One-It-Wonder und die Nachtigall, die singt sich diese Lieder aus dem Leib. Mega gut. Mich würde auch interessieren, also wie hat sich der Gesang über die Jahrhunderte entwickelt? Gibt es da Trends oder gab es Phasen oder gibt es dann einen Vogel, der aus einem anderen Land kommt und der da gar nicht ankommt irgendwie mit wo ja das ist doch die 80er Kram haben wir doch schon vor 20 Jahren so gesungen oder wie wie ist das? So weg, tschüss, tschüss Vogel, tschüss. Fliegt weg. Schwierig. Vögel. Ich hatte ja immer Wellensittiche, die haben immer die ganze Zeit geschrien und dann hast du einfach ein Handtuch drüber gelegt. Das ist für dich einfach der Urban Myth funktioniert. Geht da auf, du machst dann was drüber und die sind sofort weg. Und so habe ich mich auch vorgestellt in der Kuschel-Kuschel-Ecke. Einfach Tür zu, Decke drauf, weg, raus, ausknopf. Die waren immer aufgeregt beim Fernsehen lief und so. Vielleicht warst du zu gut behütet, vielleicht ist das das, wenn du schläfst, musst du angegriffen werden, damit dein Körper irgendwann weiss, ich kann nicht den ganzen Tag schlafen, ich muss auch aufmerksam sein. Aber als Einzelkind passiert ja auch nicht so viel. Ja, eben. Als Einzelkind spielst du mit dir selber und schläfst. Du, wenn du Brüder hast, ich kann das aus eigener Erfahrung, wenn du da einmal kurz einlegst, ist dein Gameboy weg. Gameboy weg, das Gesicht ist bemalt, deine Nase ist wirklich weg. Ja, und deine Mutter denkt, du hättest irgendwas angestellt, weil du direkt verpetzt wirst und direkt irgendwas abgewälzt wird auf dich. Genau. Du musst einfach wachsam sein die ganze Zeit. Du musst scharf sein. Du musst richtig scharf sein. Ja, verstehe gut. Okay. Auch damit du nicht stirbst, ich habe ja jetzt vor kurzer Zeit meinen Mord geplant für eine Sendung. Und wie gut hat das geklappt, den Mord zu planen? Das hat ganz gut geklappt. Man recherchiert und da gibt es auch gute Informationsquellen und so. Aber das Problem ist, du willst ja als Autor von so einem Krimi-Ding nicht immer den gleichen Mord haben. Du willst ja nicht immer Stechen, Würgen, Hauen haben, sondern mal irgendwas Interessantes und dann habe ich ja so nach Giften geguckt, was gibt es für interessante Gifte und stellt sich raus, es gibt super viele Gifte, mit denen man super leicht töten kann, weil die einfach super schwer nachzuweisen sind, leicht erhältlich, wunderbar, dramaturgisches Problem für mich, die wirken sehr langsam, also das ist sowas wie, ich vergifte dich jetzt und wenn du jetzt zwei Wochen nicht zum Arzt gehst, bist du tot. Aber habe ich denn Symptome? Du hast Symptome, gewisse Symptome, aber recht generische Symptome, Übelkeit, Kopfschmerzen, und das ist dann nur ein Timer, wenn du zwei Wochen nicht zum Arzt gehst, bist du tot. Und ich habe das gelesen und dachte mir, fuck it, ich wäre sofort tot. Selbst wenn ich das merken würde. Ich auch. Mir ist schlecht und Google-Symptome, ja, sie müssen diese Woche zum Arzt, ja, das geht von alleine weg und so. Das ist die perfekte Kryptonitwaffe gegen mich, weil ich unter gar keinen Umständen zum Arzt gehen würde, egal was passieren würde. Aber dafür hört man, dafür, dass das so ein super Mechanismus ist, hat man davon relativ wenig. Ja, weil viele Leute dann vielleicht auch einfach zum Arzt gehen, Leute, die bedroht sind als Mordopfer, die einfach wissen, da kommt da ist jemand hinterher. Selbst dann würde man ja viel davon hören. Selbst dann würde man ja hören, oh, die Ärztekammer berichtet, immer mehr Leute sind mit Rizin vergiftet worden. Ja, ich weiß es auch nicht genau, vielleicht findet man das nicht oder so, aber es ist halt dramaturgisch uninteressant, wenn die Person einfach irgendwann random stirbt und man sagt, hm, was haben sie denn vor zwei Wochen gemacht? Diesen Agatha Christie-Film, Mord im Ruheabteil, will ich auch nicht sehen, wenn dann da quasi der grosse Mord, alles beginnt mega spannend und schnell und dann wird jemand vergiftet. Aber dann ist ein Film, ein boring Film, wie jemand zwei Wochen normal durchs Leben geht. Ja, und es ist ja oft so, dass sich Ehepartner gegenseitig umbringen und so und die leben ja dann noch zwei Wochen lang miteinander und wirklich so, du Schatz, hast du mal überlegt, ob wir für die Steuer auch die neuen Lampenbezüge einreichen können, weil das ist ja schon das Arbeitszimmer, oder? Wann ist sie tot? Und der Mann die ganze Zeit so, ich habe noch ein paar Fragen an dich heute. Folgende Sachen, wo liegt dein Testament, wo liegt mein Testament? Kannst du nochmal alle Passwörter, die wir haben, aufschreiben? Aber daran könnte man es natürlich zurückführen, dass es auffälliges Verhalten ist, um den Täter zu stellen.
Aber so spannend ist es auch nicht.
Aber jetzt eine spannende Rom-Com, und zwar Mann will Frau umbringen.
Oh ja, geil.
Aber sie verlieben sich neu ineinander, weil das Bewusstsein,
dass sie nicht mehr da ist, triggert ihn dazu,
dass sie zusammen die Dinge machen, die sie eigentlich immer schon machen wollten. Er lernt sie neu kennen, das ist wieder der Song Pina Colada, wo sie sich neu kennenlernen dann. So ein umgekehrtes Blue Valentine. Erstens ist die Beziehung furchtbar und du denkst, bitte, bitte bringt euch um, bitte. Sie bringen sich um. Sie bringen sich um und dann aber merkt man, wird es immer besser und sie machen Cute Meet und spielen Ukulele auf einem Auto. Am Ende muss sie aber sterben, es ist zu spät. Ja klar, sie stirbt sie, das ist klar. Sie stirbt. Aber er bereut es und stellt sich dann auch und niemand glaubt ihm und Staffel zwei und was auch immer. Aber ja, das ist vor allem, ich meine, in zwei Wochen, du hast zwei Wochen Zeit, um zum Arzt zu gehen. Haben die schon mal versucht, einen Arzttermin zu bekommen? Ja. Ich meine, selbst wenn du weißt, oh, ich bin vergiftet,
ich habe jetzt noch neun Tage
Zeit, vergiss es.
Und dann kriegst du irgendwie so ein...
Wir haben Anfang April den nächsten Termin.
Ja, genau. Die Sache ist nur die,
ich habe ja auf Wikipedia mal geguckt, und wenn
ich jetzt in einer Woche keinen Termin bekomme, dann sterbe
ich leider. Ja, sie können halt
morgens zur Sprechstunde kommen, aber keine Garantie.
Da müssen wir vielleicht auch sehr lange warten. Okay,
dann würde ich einfach mal kommen, weil die Alternative ist
der Tod. Ja, das wissen wir ja
Vielen Dank. leider. Ja, Sie können halt morgens zur Sprechstunde kommen, aber keine Garantie. Da müssen Sie vielleicht auch sehr lange warten. Okay, ja, dann würde ich einfach mal kommen, weil die Alternative ist der
Tod. Ja, das wissen wir ja
nicht. Also, wie man jetzt gegoogelt, ne?
Und haben Sie noch einen Kollegen oder so?
Nein, nein.
Okay. Nein, tschüss.
Wiederhören. Tschüss, nein,
nein.
Und da findest du den Termin bei irgendwie so
vier Stunden Autofahrt aus der Stadt, bei irgendwie so einem Dorfdoktor. Das ist schwierig, das ist wirklich schwierig. Gleich die beste Waffe. Die Waffe macht sich das schlechte Gesundheitssystem zu eigen. Wenn du eine Schusswunde hättest und du willst damit nicht zur Polizei gehen, aus irgendwelchen Gründen, weil du dich selber bespudasten wür würde. Wo willst du hingehen? Weil in allen Krimi-Romanen und Filmen und so gibt es dann immer diesen Einarzt, der sich auskennt und so. Mr. Barnaby. Mr. Barnaby. Der einfach so, ja, ich rufe ihn an, dieser Gangsterart. Genau, ich hätte das nicht. Ich hätte das nicht. Ich würde zu diesen Medi-Studenten gehen, die ich kenne. Ja, so dieser Gangsterarzt. Genau. Ich hätte das nicht. Ich hätte das nicht. Ich würde zu diesen Medischudenten gehen, die ich kenne. Ja, gute Idee. In der Hoffnung, dass sie mich zusammenflicken, aber keine Ahnung. Und dann wüsste ich auch nicht, würde ich dann nachts anrufen. Ein Tierarzt oder so vielleicht sowas? Haben Tierärzte auch Schweigepflicht? Gibt es da sowas wie Patienten, Arzt, Geheimnis, Daniela? Die Ärzte haben Schweigepflicht. Ja, und warum ist unsere Katze jetzt so übergewichtig? Tut mir leid, das ist vertraulich, dass die Ärzte haben Schweigepflicht. Wenn du sie fragst, reden sie nicht. Ist es Lebra oder ist es Gicht? Sie sagen es dir nicht.
Ausserdem Zebra.
Aber also ich glaube, man kann schon Leute umbringen, das geht schon.
Das Problem ist halt, du müsstest halt nur jemanden umbringen, der du dich kennst.
Ansonsten schwierig, aber so geht.
Hat man mal ein Pferd gegenüber vom Zebra gestellt und mal geguckt, wie die aufeinander reagieren? Denkt das Zebra, das Pferd ist bemalt? Zeckt das Zebra, nein, ich bin anders, wir sind beide einfach anders? Wer versucht, wem die Farbe vom Körper zu denken? Wer versucht, wem die Farbe vom Körper zu denken? Wer entdeckt wen als was? Das finde ich, finde ich spannend. Wer denkt denn, was ist hier gerade los? Oder denkt das Pferd, oh, der hat Uniform an oder der ist irgendwie Teil einer Gang? Denkt das Zebra, ich würde gerne so aussehen wie das Pferd? Oder denkt das Pferd, ich würde lieber so aussehen wie das Zebra? Wollen beide lieber der andere sein? Stichwort, man will lieber was anderes sein, als man die ganze hat. Genau, die Streifen des Nachbarns sind immer schöner. Genau, das Pferd des anderen ist schöner. Ja, gute Frage. Ist eine gute Sendung, einfach mal Tiere gegenüberstellen. Nee, nur Zebras und Pferde. Zebra und Pferde einfach. Die Sendung heißt Zebra und Pferde. Und man denkt, es ist wieder so eine nervige Zooshow. Nein, es ist viel langweiliger als das. Wir haben kein Und, wir haben nur Zebra und Pferde. Wir haben kein Etc, wir haben kein Co, wir haben nur Zebra. Wir haben ein ausgeschriebenes UND, Zebra und Pferd. Nein, wir haben auch nicht Zebras und Pferde. Wir haben Jerry das Zebra und Bernd das Pferd. Und die gucken sich an mit ihren länglichen Gesichtern und den kleinen zur Seite stehen. Was ist denn da los? Und dann guckt man mal, was die machen die ganze Zeit. Wir schalten immer mal wieder rein. Das ist auch keine Sendung, die jetzt dann so die ganze Stunde läuft. Die kommt immer mal wieder, wie so zwischen Werbeblöcken, wie die Meinzelmännchen. Wir gucken immer mal wieder rein. Wir schalten mal wieder rein. Ja, auch so, wenn die Nachrichten gerade nichts haben einfach. Dann wir schalten noch mal kurz zu Zebra und Pferd. Und man sieht nur so so der eine ist in der Raummitte, der andere eher in der Ecke. Also es gibt schon Dominanzgebaren auf jeden Fall.
Aber erkennen sich, wie kult man das, erkennen sich Zebra und Pferd?
Ja genau, also erkennen die sich besser nach diesem theoretischen biologischen Speziesgebilde oder könnte jetzt zum Beispiel ein Frosch besser mit einem Pferd als ein Zebra mit einem Pferd? Könnte ein Frosch besser mit einem Salamander sprechen als ein Zebra mit einem Pferd? Das ist doch die Frage. Ja, aber das ist ja eigentlich die Frage. Genau, die Frage, weil die Biologie stellt sich ja immer die Frage, wie nah sind Tiere aneinander, wie soll man die klassifizieren und warum nicht einfach sagen, durch können die miteinander.
Da verstehen die sich. So Katze und Hund, die verstehen sich manchmal. Aber was ist jetzt einfach mit einem Frosch und irgendwie mit so einem Lemuren? Also fremdeln die komplett sich fremdeln? Oder können die so, ja passt schon, bisschen wie der Typ. Wir können miteinander, wir können nicht miteinander. Ja, genau. Das mal als biologisches Grundsatz. Und dann einfach beide in so einer schönen Kuschel-Ecke, in so einer Lounge, irgendwo auch so eine, wir stellen mal eine Playstation hin mit zwei Controllern. Einfach als Angebot, Tekken läuft, ja, und wir gucken einfach mal, was passiert. Kein Zwang, kein Zwang. Tekken läuft, die beiden Maschinen, die beiden Gegner gucken und es steht Press A to start oder sowas, die beiden Wippen hin und her, ausgestreckten Fäusten. Finde ich eine gute Idee. Ist eine gute Sendung. Ist natürlich schwer ein Zebra zu bekommen. Das ist das Problem. Und ich glaube, die haben ja so diese optische Illusionsbemalung, vielleicht kann man die gar nicht gut filmen. Ja, du denkst, die sind weiter weg, Achtung, Zebras, a piranera than they are. Man denkt, die sind weiter weg, als sie sind, weil das verwirrt einen, dieses Streifen. Ja. Machen längliche Streifen dick oder dünn? Oh, das weiß ich nicht, ehrlich gesagt. Ist ja so eine Moderegel. Ich glaube, so nach oben machen sie dick, glaube ich. Nach oben machen sie dick. Weil dann kann man ja abzählen, wie viele Streifen es sind.
Und je mehr Streifen, desto dicker die Person.
Wohingegen von oben nach unten lässt sich höher erscheinen.
Das ist der Merksatz.
Ich glaube, das ist die Idee dahinter.
Aber ohne hinzugucken, in welche Richtung sind Zebras gestreift?
Oben und unten.
Vertikal?
Ja.
Weil die Gras, die wollen im hohen Gras untergehen. Die wollen im hohen Gras untergehen. Checkt auch keiner mit Zebras, oder? Doch, doch. Ja gut, ich meine jetzt natürlich moderne Wissenschaft oder so, aber Leute aus der Antike sehen Zebra und denken sich, was soll das denn?
Also ich meine,
komm mal, wir verstehen fast nichts, aber wie sollen wir das denn? Die Welt war lange Zeit
viel zu schwer eingestellt.
Der Schwierigkeitsgrad war
viel zu hoch, Mittelalter,
Blitz und Donner und die so, ja Leute,
was sollen wir denn machen? Wir
leben bis wir 25 sind.
Wer soll das denn verstehen?
Es ist neulich übrigens eine weitere Meldung aus dem Tierreich, die mich sehr interessiert hat. Es gab neulich nämlich den Bericht, dass zum ersten Mal ein Mensch mit einem fehlerhaften Herz eine Herztransplantation bekommen hat von einem Schweineherz. Oh, da wurde irgendwie, es war sogar in Deutschland, wurde ein, speziell gezüchtet, dieses Schwein, so dass da jetzt keine, ja, Viren drin sind oder was auch immer, die sonst immer in Schweinen vorkommen. Und dieses Schweineherz war dann so gut dafür geeignet, die wurden extra dafür gezüchtet, dass es dann als erstes mal einem Menschen eingesetzt werden konnte. Und der hat 61 Tage Überlebnis dann gestorben. Und dann ging die Untersuchung los, warum der gestorben ist, Tschetski-Unfall, sich überfressen. Und dann kam raus, dass bei der OP nachlässig gehandelt wurde. Und ich dachte mir die ganze Zeit, Nachlässigkeit war der Grund? Wer war denn so gechillt bei der ersten Operation, wo man ein Tierherz in einen Menschen pflanzt? Wer war da so chillt? Wer macht das nebenbei? Wer macht das nebenbei nachlässig? Erstmal, jeglicher Chirurg, der nachlässig arbeitet, hat eh schon nichts in diesem Berufsfeld verloren. Aber es muss der most chill guy oder girl auf der Welt sein, wenn du sagst, oh, ihr heisst nicht, ihr kurz zusammen. Leute, ich muss los, haut rein, näht immer wieder zusammen, ich bin hier durch. Alle mega nervös und er so, ey, kommt erst einmal ein bisschen runter, okay? Also hat gestern jemand eine neue Folge Better Call Saul guckt, also ich fand mich mega. Er macht so, könntest du mal ein bisschen Musik anmachen? Und ich dachte mir, Nachlässigkeit? Das ist schon bitter. Nachlässigkeit. Vor allem dieses riesige Menschheitsexperiment, das so viele Türen aufstoßen konnte, scheitert wegen Nachlässigkeit. Aber der Typ denkt sich doch alles, ah fuck, stimmt. Diese eine Röhre da, da habe ich mir schon gedacht, ob das so rühre. Sie meinen Adern. Ja, komm, dass die da so rumzappelt, dass die nirgendwo angeschlossen war, da habe ich mir schon gedacht, naja. Aber so entspannt. Aber ich meine Schweine, keine Ahnung, wie das funktioniert Aber so entspannt wie er bei dieser Schweineoperation, wäre ich gern irgendwann mal in meinem Leben. Ja. Aber das ist schon verrückt, wenn das klappt, dann sind wir ja eigentlich nur noch einen Schritt von der Bojack Horseman Welt entfernt, wo einfach beliebige Körperteile von Pferden kommen. Und wenn jemand irgendwie die Beine verloren hat, kriegt der dann Hufe oder was einfach. Ich meine, wenn das klappt, warum denn dann nicht alles? Ich meine, ist das denn eigentlich die Zukunft der Menschheit, zu sagen, wenn irgendwann das möglich ist und man kann halt wirklich dann, keine Ahnung, jetzt nicht Flügel, aber vielleicht wirklich Pferdebeine bekommen statt Beinen, sagt man irgendwann, warum denn nicht alle Menschen haben das? Ich will so einen Hacker hinten von so einem Kamele. Ja, und dann hast du so best of all worlds, kannst du dann dir aus allen Tieren die richtigen Körperteile zusammenstellen. Du hast dann Adleraugen und Quallen, nix, Quallen sind raus. Ich habe hinten so einen ganz langen Schweif mit so Quallen, Tentakeln. Oh ja, das ist eine Plastiktüte. Ja, genau, so ganz viele Plastiktüten hinter mir. Wenn Leute mich anfassen, dann werden die verbrannt. Ist schon verrückt. Was hättest du alles? Adleraugen finde ich super. Adleraugen finde ich ganz, ganz toll. Ja, ich glaube, ich will so ganz viele Augen haben, wie so eine Fliege oder so, wenn alles so ganz langsam sehen können, dass ich dann, na gut, aber es wird auch langweilig gleich, wenn alles so langsam ist. aber das und wiederkäuern natürlich auch eine geile Idee, zu sagen, du kannst jederzeit sagen, boah, mein Frühstück würde ich gerne nochmal kauen jetzt gerade, einfach nochmal kauen und einfach anstatt, das ist ideal für Diäten, anstatt einfach was Neues zu essen, kaust du einfach deinen Mageninhalt nochmal und es ist ideal. Ich hätte gerne Giraffenbeine und Arme, sodass ich immer wieder, wenn ich dann fertig bin, da wo ich dann gerade bin, habe mir einen Döner geholt, packe den in meinen Rucksack und dann trabe ich nach Hause. Dann wird sich nach vorne auf alle Viere auf meine Giraffenärmchen und Beinchen gestellt und dann wird losgelaufen. Und dann bin ich so schnell. Sind Giraffen sehr schnell eigentlich? Ja, und das Beste ist, ich kann ja über Staus gehen. Oh ja, das ist eine gute Idee. Weil mein Bauch ist so weit oben, weil ich so lange Beinchen, Ärmchen habe. Ich finde das interessant, dass gerade du als grosser Mensch sagst, du willst noch grösser sein, noch mehr Schwierigkeiten haben, einen Flugzeugplatz zu finden. Grosse Debatte übrigens, Stichwort Grösse. Ich habe erzählt, ich habe berichtet von meinem Konzertbesuch bei den Simple Minds. Ja, du hast aus mehreren Seiten Shitstorms bekommen. Ja, und zwar erst mal kamen, es waren zwei Nachrichten, also vielleicht sollten wir auch auf unsere Wortwahl achten, eben Dinge heraufbeschwören, von denen wir gar keine Probleme haben. Aber es kam eine Nachricht, bist du wirklich so ein Arschloch, dass du... Kurz, worum ging es? Du warst beim Simple-Minds-Konzert, versperrst anderen Leuten den Weg. Es ging darum, dass ich, sollte ein großer Mensch wie ich beim Konzert Rücksicht auf andere nehmen, ganz doof plakativ formuliert, oder darf ich auch in der Mitte stehen oder sowas, wenn ich früh komme beim Konzert, weil ich gerne meine Idole, die Simple Minds, nahe sehen will und komme deswegen sehr früh und stelle mich vorne hin, ist es erlaubt als grosser Mensch oder sollen grosse Menschen generell einfach hinten stehen bei Konzerten? So, und dann kam eine Nachricht, du bonniert das Arschloch, du gehörst zu den 0,5 Prozent der Welt, die Rücksicht nehmen müssen auf kleinere Menschen, von daher nach hinten mit dir. Und dann kam eine andere Nachricht, die fing an mit, Stefan, es muss aufhören, und ich dachte mir, okay, here we go, das ist die zweite Nachricht, die in die Richtung geht, aber es muss aufhören, dass du dich für deine Grösse schämst. Ich dachte mir, wow, that took a turn. Du kannst dich hinstellen, wo du willst, jeder Mensch ist anders. So, alle müssen drückzüglich auf alle nehmen. Können wir jetzt diese beiden Personen in den Podcast einladen und die so lange in den Raum sperren, bis die ihre Probleme gehen? Spin-off von Zebra und Pferd. Ja. Und dann habe ich jetzt... Gross gegen klein. Und jetzt habe ich noch eine neue Nachricht bekommen, wo genau diese Diskussion bei einem amerikanischen Instagram-Post diskutiert wurde. Und in den Kommentaren ist ganz, ganz einheitlich eigentlich, wenn man gross ist und man möchte aber auch ein Konzert genießen, dann muss man das hinkriegen. Die Leute hinter dir können sich ja arrangieren. Natürlich sollte man sich nicht vor die kleinsten Menschen stellen, aber man so kann sich ja ... Was macht das denn für einen Unterschied, ob du jetzt klein bist und nichts siehst oder mittelgross bist und nichts siehst, ist ja auch dann egal, oder? Naja, also es ist ja, nee, es ist ja nicht null oder eins. Sollte man sich nicht eher vor kleinen Leuten stellen, weil die ja auch sonst nichts sehen würden? Sollten sich nicht eigentlich immer die kleinsten und die grössten zusammensuchen und die Grossen stellen sich vor, die Kleinen ja eh nicht sehen. Alle Grossen nehmen die Kleinen auf die Schulter. So. Was ich, nee, und dann sehen die Mittelgrossen nichts mehr. Das ist ein großes Problem. Nee, das ist nicht Null oder Eins. Die kleinen Menschen sehen ja ein bisschen was bei hinter mittelgrossen Menschen, worin sie mittelgrossen Menschen auch noch sehr viel hinter mir sehen können. Ist ein bisschen, aber ein Kommentar gefiel mir sehr gut von einer Frau in einem Kommentar, die meinte, no, no, no, this is payback for airplane seats. Ah, okay. Yes, yes, yes, yes. Man fliegt in etwa, zumindest war das mal so häufig, wie man zu Konzerten geht, und wir erleben regelmäßig zu enge Airplane-Seeds, wir können nicht unsere Beine ausstrecken. Und Konzerte sind einfach nur Payback dafür. Okay. Gut, finde ich gut, dass wir das geklärt haben. Ja. Und es wird natürlich nicht leichter, wenn du deine Giraffenbeine hast. Dann hast du natürlich ein Problem, weil dann, spätestens da wird selbst ich sagen, wenn du extra diese schwerwiegende Operation, die einmal wiederholt werden musste wegen Nachlässigkeit, wenn du die extra durchziehst, um deine Grafenbeine zu bekommen. Mit den scheiß Erzen, mit der Nachlässigkeit. Woran denken die denn immer? Die kriegen doch schon viel Geld und alles geht's denen nicht gut, dass die immer abgelenkt sind. Das sind diese ganzen genialen Fernsehserien. Stefan, ihr mit euren
Goldfeder und dann
wie geht's weiter und Cliffhanger und so,
ihr lenkt die Chirurgen ab.
Erkennt das Zebra jetzt das
Pferd? Das
fragen die sich die ganze Zeit, während sie
mir meine Giraffenbeine dran machen.
Aber ich meine, es gibt dann auch Giraffen,
die einfach dann, Zebras, die
ein anderes Muster haben, die dann von links nach rechts gestreift sind oder so, also die dann ganz anders aussehen. Zebras. So als Mutation oder so, das muss sich ja auch irgendwie entwickeln. Ja. Ja stimmt, wie der Schmetterling, der die 98 drauf steht. Ja, den muss ich nochmal finden. Ah, der war sehr schön. Es gibt einen Schmetterling, der einfach eine ganz klare Zahl, 93, es sieht nicht mal aus wie zwei Punkte oder so.
Nee, nee, es ist einfach die Zahl.
Sans Serif, ganz klasse, zack, 83.
Einfach wunderbar.
Oder einfach mal so ein Pferd, wo einfach LOL draufsteht, einfach so wirklich einfach, okay.
Ich meine, wie viele Milliarden Zebras gibt es auf der Welt? Da gibt es doch eins, wo einfach LOL draufsteht. 86. Ja, finde ich super, muss man mal finden. Das finde ich fantastisch. Aber finde ich eine gute Idee. Ich finde, E-Tier, Tiersendungen haben sich ein bisschen in der Sackgasse manövriert. Wir haben jetzt schon alles gesehen, Tier A frisst Tier B, B läuft weg, haben wir alles gesehen. So, jetzt, ich will die Gegenüberstellungen. Ab gestern übrigens bei Apple Plus, Prehistoric World meine ich, heißt diese. Ach ja, mit den animierten Dinos, ne? Endlich mal wieder eine geile animierte Dino-Serie, ist irgendwie limited, aber geil gesprochen, ich freue mich da sehr drauf. Prehistoric Planet. Ist das nicht von Obama gesprochen?
Gibt es nicht irgendeine Tierdoku, die von Obama
gesprochen wurde? Nee, das ist von David Attenborough.
Ach so, na gut.
Prehistoric Planet, jetzt auf Apple Plus.
Ja, er wird mal Zeit für mich,
Apple Plus zu kaufen. Ja, Moment mal, und die
der erzählt
dann, was andere Leute animiert
haben? Also er
kommentiert das, was er vorhin gesagt hat, was die Leute animieren sollen, die da arbeiten? Er kommentiert die Bilder, die Animateure geanimateurt haben. Moment mal, also der setzt sich hin und sagt, ah, hier sehen Sie das ganz charakteristische Verhalten eines Raptors, Sie sehen, wie er seine Eier von links nach rechts bewegt. Und das hat aber irgendjemand davor so animiert und jetzt interpretiert er das Verhalten, was jemand anders willentlich so gebaut hat? Genau, er erzählt eigentlich die ganze Zeit, hier hat sich der Animateur gedacht, einen T-Rex zu zeichnen. Genau, hier sehen wir eine After Effects-Maske, dass der Lichtschatten hier nicht auf den Eiern liegt.
Und wenn Sie hier dieses Pinselwerkzeug nehmen, dann können Sie das hier einmal ausmalen.
Oh, hier hat anscheinend was mit dem Rotoscoping nicht geklappt.
Da sehen wir hier noch ein bisschen was vom Hintergrundbild mit.
Da können Sie sich auch mal merken, fühlt sich zu Hause.
Sieht man hier bei dem Quetzalquadlus ganz gut.
Wenn Sie Shift drücken, können Sie den Maßstab behalten.
Die können... Wacken fühlt sich zu Hause. Sieht man hier bei dem Quetzal-Quadlus ganz gut. Wenn Sie Shift drücken, können Sie den Maßstab behalten. Sie können die Bildverhältnisse nicht verändern. Und hier tatsächlich gibt es ein paar Realaufnahmen, das sind echte Eier, die haben wir angemalt und vergrößert. Dafür auch hier einfach das Pinselwerkzeug, wir den Zauberstab nehmen und dann können wir hier. Aber es ist doch albern, oder? Es ist ein bisschen albern, aber ich finde es fantastisch. Also der Trailer sieht wirklich fantastisch aus. Wir haben auch befederte Dinosaurier. Also es ist eigentlich, ja, ich bin gespannt. Ich glaube auch, wenn man das Stück für Stück macht, wenn der so eine Fehler hat, weil der tatsächlich, das ist mir letztens noch mal komplett gekommen, weil ich spiele ja World of Warcraft, wo du so durch die Gegend läufst und mehr oder weniger alle Gegner umbringst und da gibt es auch eine Zone, in der es Dinosaurier gibt, ganz verschiedene Dinosaurier und da gibt es auch Raptoren und die Raptoren tragen auch Federn, aber als Schmuck, also die tragen dann so eine Art Stirnband und da strecken Federn drin oder so Armbänder und da strecken Federn drin. Haben die denn normale Menschenärme? Nee, nee, die haben Körper wie Raptoren. Und wie haben die das dann hingekriegt? Die haben anscheinend irgendeine Form von Kultur entwickelt, in der sie Federn tragen. Was rückblickend ja total interessant ist, weil die vielleicht damals in den frühen Nullerjahren, als das Spiel entwickelt wurde, dachten, Moment, wie soll das Federn? Also wir bauen das schon ein, aber die haben die halt als Armband getragen vielleicht oder so. Oder war das deren Form sozusagen über den Umweg den wissenschaftlichen Stand einzubauen ins Spiel, zu sagen, die haben Federn? Weil warum würden die sich gerade mit Federn schmücken, warum nicht mit Steinen oder was auch immer? Weil Federschmuck wirklich naheliegend ist. Es ist schon naheliegend, aber das fand ich so toll. Weil du hast ja immer das Problem in so einem MMO, die Gegner sollen ja auch was droppen. Also du lootest sie dann und dann kriegst du irgendwas. Und wenn du gegen andere Menschen kämpfst, dann haben die Geld dabei. Super. Aber du musst dir ja für jedes Tier irgendwas aus den Fingern saugen. Der Raptor hat 26 Liter Schleim gedroppt. Genau, was der dabei hat. Und deswegen droppen die Raptoren halt immer Federn, die du dann verkaufen kannst. Das finde ich doof. Klauen, grosse Klauen. Klauen haben sie auch, ja. Gift. Droppen Gift. Raptoren haben Gift? Weiß ich nicht. Er hat auch keine Federn in Form von ... Die schmücken sich mit Gift oder was. Die schmücken sich mit Gift oder was. Nein. Du hast dann zwei Wochen Zeit, um zum Heiler zu gehen, ansonsten ist sein Charakter tot. Er hatte bei Jurassic Park diese eine, die nur hat doch Gift in die Augen gesprüht von Newman. War das Gift? Ja, er hat gesagt, Newman. Ich dachte, es war einfach Erbrochenes. Newman. Und der hat Newman. Terry? Und dann hat er Gift in die Augen gesprüht. Das war doch. Naja, also ich freue mich sehr auf diese Dokuserie. Ich lasse es nächste Woche in Ruhe drüber reden. Auf jeden Fall, schaut das an und dann will ich ein Review haben. Und falls ihr ein Zebra besitzt, meldet euch gerne, weil Pferde finden wir genug in Deutschland. Wir fahren euer Zebra zu dem Pferd für eine Gegenüberstellung. Wir machen erst die Schattenwand, sodass die sich erst kennenlernen, ohne zu geruch, dass sie anders aussehen. Und dann aber der Grand Reveal, oh, Schattenwand weg, weggetragen von Praktikanten und dann sehen die sich und sehen, du siehst ja ganz verrückt aus. Habe ich jetzt auch gehört, es gibt so verschiedene Dating, also Beindating-Methoden mit den fünf Sinnen. Also erst anfassen, dann riechen aneinander, fühlen und am Ende darf man sich erst sehen. Nur anfassen und blind oder was? Genau, die ganze Zeit ist man blind und so. Also du hast irgendwas in der Nase, irgendwas in den Ohren und irgendwas auf den Augen und darfst dann aber anfassen? Genau. Und man darf anfassen und darf sich dann riechen, darf sich hören und am Ende darf man sich sehen. Und auf dem Weg dahin, vielleicht weiß ich gar nicht, ob man sich sehen darf, auf dem Weg dahin gibt es verschiedene Möglichkeiten, sich zu matchen, wenn beide die in den Arm hochnehmen. Und das ist eine App? Ne, ne, ne, das ist eine, so trifft man sich, ist wie Blind Dating. Ach so. Also so Speed Dating. Und aber kannst du schon bei Riechen sagen, nee, kein Interesse? Genau. Ist das das Demütigendste, was es überhaupt gibt? In der Riechphase dann zu sagen, nee, danke. Das siehst du ja nicht. Du siehst ja nicht, dass die Person vor dir nicht bereit ist. Aber du siehst ja, dass dieser Prozess nicht weitergeht. Nee, nee, neeh, jeder riecht jeden. Ach so. Und, ähm, wenn nicht beide beim Riechen den Arm hochgenommen haben, wollen die sich nicht so gerne riechen. Und am Ende kriegst du eine Mail, wer dich auch gematcht hat oder so. Ja, ist ja fantastisch, ich finde das super, so geil. That's how, that's how we, that's how we roll now. Schaut immer, habt immer ein Umfeld im Auge, wo kann ich mich jetzt schnell festhalten. Genau, nicht, dass ihr uns wegfliegt.
Nee, niemand fliegt diese Woche weg.
Das müssen wir hinkriegen.
Wir heben aber ab. Macht's gut, wir heben ab.
Ciao, wir heben ab, ciao.
It's a Worst Bird Production.